let's make a London Fog tres leches cake
Rogue is my go-to cup of tea pretty much
every morning but if you add a little
milk and vanilla you've got a London Fog
so if you love to just as much as I do
you're going to love this recipe this
tres leches cake recipe does have a few
steps but they're easy to follow and
incorporating the earl gray vanilla and
of course the milk into it is so simple
all you have to do is let the tea bag
soak in the evaporated milk for 15
minutes before adding the rest of the
ingredients and make sure to drown the
cake with the mixture I topped it up
with some group vanilla cream cacao
powder orange sets and dark chocolate
shavings and it's good to go